こんにちは！はじめしゃちょー(忍者)と
まさき取締役(村長)です！
は：まさきさん、
ま：はい
ま：おお！！
（まさきさん軽く吹き出す）
はい、というわけでですね
今こちらに有名なものを１００個集めました！！不味くてです
なんかパッと見わかんないのあります？
基本的に多分一度は食べた事あるというか
味はわかるだろうな、っていうやつを１００種類集めてみました
大体わかるでしょ
これ言ったらさ、非国民って言われそうなの言っていい？
いいよ
俺これとこれに関しては食べた事ない・・・
ゑ！！
あはっｗ
という訳で
私、お菓子、大好き芸人でございます
お菓子大好きなんで～
利きお菓子というわけでもないんですけども
お菓子の味を食べただけでお菓子の名称を答えれる訳はないと思いますがやってみたいと思います
んだと思います
ま：おかしな能力ですね　笑
なので、こちらに１００個今お菓子があるので
今から目隠しして
食べて、それの味を答えます
流石に今これ全部何があるかっていうのを全部把握してないし
名前も一個ずつ覚えてないので
何が来るかわからない状況で今から
お菓子を１００個食べて１００問中何問正解できるかで
お菓子マイスターの
ま：あぁ～
ポイントが決まると
ま：なるほどね
ま：まぁマイスターだったら１００いけるね
は：１００いけますよ！！
あっ、じゃあ９５点いったらお菓子マイスターね
逆に五点いったら、まじで、もう嬉しい
自動車学校通い直しだからね
じゃあもうさっそく食べていきましょう！！
ま：へい！
えっと、一応ルールとしては
若干合ってたら
言いたいことが合ってたら
伝わってきたら、まるということで
では、１００問
よろしくお願いします！！！
ま：どうしようかねぇ
簡単めなところからいこうかな
いやー
これマジで緊張するなぁ
ま：あっ、じゃあ好きそうなやつからいくわ
ま：最初はこれ、いきまーす
ま：一個目
は：はい！
ま：これ多分好きだと思う
は：あっ
は：カントリーマアム！
（ピンポーン）
（はじめしゃしょー喜び）
は：うぇっほ
ま：次これいきまーす
は：うぇっ？
は：何これ
は：えっ？
待って、何これ？
は：あっ　あっ
ま：初級だよ？これ
は：プリッツでしょ？
（ピンポーン）
は：よしよしよし
は：はぁ　はぁ　はぁ　怖かったー
ま：これ、いきまーす
は：怖いのやだよぉ
ま：いきまーす
は：あっ
は：何　何　何？
は：あっキャラメルなんだよなぁ
は：キャラメルのポップコーンあれでしょ？？
ま：あふふぅん♥
は：えっ、待って待って
は：パッケージの説明していい？
ま：うん
は：あのあれでしょ？赤いやつでしょ？
ま：そうそうそうそう
は：赤い、なんかあのー変な目くりくりのキャラが描いてあるやつ
（ピンポーン）
は：本当？合ってる？
ま：合ってる合ってる
は：なんていうの？あれ
は：あっ
ま：次これいっちゃお
ま：これです
ま：いきまーす
は：はい
は：えっ
は：ビーノ？
（ピンポーン）
は：えっ本当に合ってた？
ま：合ってる
は：うわ今さやえんどうかビーノですっごい迷ったんだけど
さやえんどうはもっと細いんだよ、多分
ま：あ！そうなんだぁ！
え俺ビーノって名前絶対出てこない
は：PSvitaしか出てこないよね(小声)ごめん次行きましょう！
ま：はい
は：ハッピーターン！待ってハッピ－！
忍者めし
えっ！当たった！？
ま：これいっぱい食べるよね
は：何このやさしい味わい
は：や、まって、もうちょ、もう一本
ま：もう一本やさしさを
は：なにこれ...
えーまって何これ～
えーそんなわかり易い？
ま：結構わかり易いと思う
は：じゃがスティック
（まさき笑う）
ま：違う。　ぶーーー。
は：正解は...？
ま：正解はサッポロポテト
は：はっあっあの...あれだ！！あの...
お野菜の奴だ、ベジタブル何とか
ま：そう、つぶつぶベジタブル
は：それはちょっと俺小学校以来食ってねーよたぶん...
は：やばいここで初ミスか！
ま：初ミス！
ま：気を付けないと
ま：もうこれで100点無くなったからね
は：やばい、ジャガイモでしょ？　♪～：ピロン（正解）
ちなみにチーズ味でしょ？
どうぶつビスケット！
（まさき笑う）
ま：惜しい
は：動物がこう印刷されている
ま：はい
は：ビスケットでしょ？
ま：うん。うふふ
ま：まあそうだけど
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：えっえっ、そんなにギリ？
ま：これ
ネーミング特徴じゃん！！
は：え、どういう名前？
ま：食べっ子どうぶつ
は：あっ
は：ふうーー、うん。
小枝だ
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：ハバネロ？
ま：ああせいかーい！
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：あ、待って待って辛いよ～
は：マーブルチョコレート
ま：せいかーい
は：冬の口どけみたい
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：びすこ
は：あれだ！あの...三角のおにぎりのお菓子だ
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：長くね？...あ、ポテロング！
は：あ！マイクポップコーン！
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：カルビーの、
ポテトチップスの、コンソメパンチのダブルだ！
♪～：ピロン（正解）
ま：超詳細に答えてくれた
は：とんがりコーン
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：なんかなげわみたいなやつでしょ？
ま：うんうんうんうんうん
は：えーっと、あれでしょ、分かるよ、あの
指になんか引っかかってるあれ...だ、あの輪っかの
輪っかの
なんか、わなげみたいな、なげわみたいな、お菓子
♪～：ピロン（正解）
（まさき笑う）
は：何ですか名前
ま：ポテコ
は：ああ、ポテコか！
わなげ...でいいやん
は：かっぱえびせん！
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：これプリングルスでしょ？
♪～：拍動の音
（まさき笑う）は：えっ、やらかしたかー？？
ま：残念！
は：チップスターでしょ！
ま：せいかーい
は：うわあ～そうだよね～
は：ポッキーのイチゴ味
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：キットカットでしょ？
は：ビックカツ！
は：カルビーポテトチップスうすしお味
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：え？？
ま：せいかーい
かむかむレモンだ！
♪～：ピロン（正解）
は：なにこれ...
は：ぉえ？？...あれだ！あれ、あのーあれあれあれ
あのーなんか
あのー薄い白いパッケージの
ココア...の奴でしょ？
（まさき笑う）　は：違う？
ココアのなんか、コーヒーぽい...何か茶色い
ココアじゃない方でしょ
ま：ココア...
は：待って待って
ま：ココア関係ないんだよな
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は：だめだーーーー
は：正解はなんですか？
ま：ココナッツサブレ！
は：ああぁ～～....これは無理っすわ～
は：チョコバット！！
(まさき笑う）
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：うまい棒なのはわかるんだけどぉ...
めんたいこ？
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：あ～よかった～
は：ルマンド！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：オーザック...？
は：源氏パイ？
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：ハートの形で分かったぁ
ま：あぁあぁあぁ
（まさき笑う）
は：これ何何なに、梅シート....梅とかわかめとかのシートみたいな奴
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：合ってる？　ま：わかめではないけど、
ま：のりね、のり。　は：あ～そうそうのりか。
おっとっと、でしょ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：ふぇ～～？
は：（ごもごもしながら何か言ってる）
（まさき嬉しみ）
は：なにこれ～
ま：まじ？これわかり易いかと思った
は：あれでしょ？キャベツ太郎の仲間みたいな奴だ！！
は：キャベツ太郎の仲間！！
ま：ぶぅぅううう～
は：何これ何これ～
ま：正解は、うまい棒のたこ焼き味
は：見ていい～？
ま：うん
は：あれなんかすっげえ..メガ（自主規制ピー）並みに大きく感じた
（まさき笑う）
は：だめだ、ちょっとここまで来ると、
ま：麻痺してきてる？
は：そう、もうちょっと分かんなかった、感覚が
は：マカダミアの...あれだぁ
あの...
♪～ピローン（正解）
ま：上位交換って言ったら可哀想だ
は：あぁ、そっかｗ
は：きのこぉ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：ポイフル
まさき笑いつつ♪～ピローン（正解）
は：コアラのマーチ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：サワーズグミ
ま：せいかぁ～い
は：ハーベスト
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：カラムーチョはこんなんじゃなかったから～
は：えっカラムーチョかなぁ
は：ん～～？？ホントに難しいこれ
ポテトチップスでこんなに難しいのあるっけ？？
は：辛いよね、でも....
は：コンソメじゃない？？
ま：ブッブ～
は：え～無理だよ分かんない、わかんなぁーい
ま：正解は、
は：はぁい
ま：カラムーチョ
は：あっ...やばい　てことは今もう既に...
ま：５問間違えたから～
は：ここ次ミスるとぉ～
は：マイスターの資格は剥奪ということかぁ
ま：うん
は：もうミスれませんね...
は：フィットチーネグミ
♪～ピローン（正解）
堅あげポテトでしょぉ
は：うまい棒の...チーズ！！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：さけるグミだ！
は：アーモンドチョコレート
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：うん、チョコボールだ
は：ブラックサンダー
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：あぁ！ピュレグミ
は：うまい棒の...コンポタージュ！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：トッポ！
は：柿の種！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：コロロ
は：アポロ
♪～ピローン（正解）
ま・は：（ポルノグラフティー口ずさむ）
は：ベビースター
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：赤い箱の...
ま：おぉ！？
は：えっとぉ、名前がうまく出て来ない...プリッツ、クラッツみたいな奴
（まさき笑う）♪～ピローン（正解）
は：ポッキー
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：アンパンマンのチョコだぁ～！
は：うまい棒のチョコだ！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：パプリコだ！
ま：カプリコ...
は：カプリコだｗｗｗ
は：チョコパイ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：たけのこの里！
は：ジャガビー
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：すっぱム～チョ！
（まさき歓喜）
は：何そんな爆笑するお菓子あんの？
は：どんだけ幸せなの
は：やんやんつけボ～でしょ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：オレオ
は：アルフォート
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：この...飴でしょ？
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は：メントシュ！
♪～ピローン（正解）
ま：いい～っすね～いい～っすね～　もう大分減ってきたぞ！
は：いいぞいいぞー
は：チェルシー
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：え～あれじゃないの？黄色いキャラメルでしぉ？
ま：もう、これはもう、ねえ...
は：わかった。良いですか～
ま：はい。
は：後半時間かかるの多くないすか
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は：パイの実！
♪～ピローン（正解）
（はじめ苦しむ）
は：あれだー、あのなんか潰してる梅の奴でしょ
は：なんかグミと同じパッケージの
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：ガーナ...
は：ヨーグレットでしょ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：チョコベビーだ
は：キシリトール！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：果汁グミ！
は：タラタラしてんじゃね～よ..？
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：アンパンマングミ
は：イーマのど飴
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：からっ...待ってカラ...
は：ブラックブラックだ！！
♪～ピローン（正解）
（まさき笑う）
は：笛ラムネだ！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：海外の...あれだ、あの
は：二百何円のグミ！
♪～ピローン（正解）
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は：何だっけ
（まさき笑う）
は：ああ～たぶんピザポテトじゃね？
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：もうさぁ
は：ピザポテトって濃いじゃん
は：全然味がないんだよ
ま：やばいよそれ
は：パイン飴だ
♪～ピローン（正解）
ま：惜しい
は：①か～
は：カルパス！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：きんかんとう～みたいな
は：待って、あの～白い袋の奴！
♪～ピローン（正解）まあ正解byまさき
は：クロレッツだ！
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：ビスコじゃないよね？
♪～ピローン（正解）　鳴らない
は：え？アルフォートじゃないの？
♪～ピローン（正解）
ま：何でこれだけ2個あったの
は：あれだ！あの
安いイカの奴だ！
ｗｗｗｗｗ♪～ピローン（正解）
ま：わ、まじ～
は：えぇ！？
（まさき笑う）
は：そんな、「まじ～」とか言って大爆笑するお菓子を...
ま：うぇっ....
（まさき大草原）
（はじめ嘔吐）は：あ、あれだ
は：ハリボの
は：タイヤ味のグミ
ま：正解
（はじめ吐きそうになる）
は：ハイチュウ
♪～ピローン（正解）
は：プッカ！
ま：うわぁ～簡単だった？
は：うん...わかりました
は：行きます
ま：はい
は：え～っと
は：コーンポタージュの袋の奴！
は：見て良いですか？
ま：どうぞ！
は：はいっ！！
は：いぇぇえええええーーーい
ま：正解数95！
ま：お菓子マイスターを認定します！！
（はじめ歓喜）
ま：ふふっ❤